on the cruise off captain Jim Hubbard
and the crew are bringing in their first
black cod set okay this door is our main
process effect here as the fish are
pulled in there instantly processed
while Kevin Mann's the roller Mike heads
the fish for their succulent meat also
called tips
they're part of the car once they head
the fish they scrape and clean the guts
and blood line then rinse them out they
sort the fish by species and size we
ever had was uh 44 pounds that was done
in Southeast Alaska
they're fully frozen within seven hours
of being caught
yeah they're pretty much still wiggling
when you get put them in the band's it
doesn't get any better than this really
but the crews off has also pulled up
quite a bit of a bycatch in the form of
slope rockfish right here sorting it or
idiot we like to call they'll ruin your
day if you get fined by them I got
poison in there fine on shore processors
pay a meager $1 a pound or unprocessed
thorny heads but Jim can sell processed
fish at up to $4 a pound wholesale the
extra work means more money for the crew
long liners take an active approach to
prevent another type of common bycatch
seabirds some of these birds are
endangered and can get caught on
longline hooks as they lunge for bait
this hangs overtop the ground lioness
it's going out and it keeps the birds
from coming down and trying to grab bait
off the hooks it's a very effective
mechanism and it does a great job of
keeping the birds out